I mean...
Ahoy, matey!
I'll have you be my first mate.
But you can call me Captain.
Captain...
Will you be deploying the hat?
That's a great idea!
Well, we will for now.
And the glasses.
Because it's a sun...
Well, I was going to say it's a sunny, sunny day, but
actually it's quite cloudy.
But we don't want to get sunburned now, do we?
My skin is so fair.
Captain Mintbeard.
Captain Minky.
That's me!
Hey, Mint, another day with you!
Hello, hello, hello!
Yes!
Hot damn Captain Crunch.
Oops, all ghosties!
I love Oopsalberries though Lance!
Oh my gosh!
Finished 12 hour shift, made it to stream while not at work,
working hard Oh my gosh Lance, thank you for the hug, I'm so
fun!
Ocho!
Get lots of rest!
12 hour shift, holy moly.
Get lots of My throat's a little sore today.
lots of rest.
Okay, Captain Crunch, but you'd better not mess up or make
your cereal all berries again, or else.
Oops, all berries.
Please don't make me clean the poop deck, Captain Minky.
I think all we have is a poop deck.
We are on a tiny, tiny boat together.
Incognito boat.
One year.
Oh, the better say it, go!
Hello, Minto, and I was like, ready to sail the seas with
Mickey combo thank you yeah don't ask about where the poop
deck is it might be behind you
um this is about a game where you you are on a boat and then
your boat goes to sink it starts to sink and you have only
you can only grab as many items as you can and then you have
to survive in your tiny rowboat with those items and things
happen and it's a bit of a roguelike
because various events can happen and so and they're quite
they're random so we will do our best to to survive and not
sleep with the fishies and we're not gonna sleep with them
either because that's the title don't sleep with the fishes.
You don't.
So, that 60 seconds game?
Like 60 seconds.
A little...
Is that the one where you're related to your wife?
I think it's a little longer.
Wait, am I thinking of the right game?
No, that's 12 minutes.
I could have fooled me, could have fooled me.
It's a nuclear shelter game.
Oh, I haven't heard of it.
Nico, thank you so much for the raid.
Hello, hello.
Binto spoilers.
Oh, oops.
Don't rewind the time.
Oh my gosh, Max, your profile picture is so funny.
Thank you, welcome back to membership.
Thank you, Situ, thank you!
Yes, it does feel similar to nuclear shelter game.
Well, I've never played that before, so we'll see.
You guys can tell me how similar it is or not.
And if we like this, and you guys recommend that, we can try
the nuclear shelter one.
60 seconds.
Ducky, thank you!
Little baby bamboo.
Oh my gosh, your baby!
You were bored!
Rinto, my MIDI keyboard arrived.
You inspired me to be creative again, so I'm going back to
playing piano in my spare time.
Thank you, Vicky.
Wow!
That's so fun!
Have fun with your keyboard!
Oh, thank you for all the gifts that you guys!
Valerious, thank you!
Leia, thank you!
Risa, thank you!
Gapot, thank you!
Try and welcome back!
Phil, thank you!
Don't become fish eat.
I won't, I won't, I won't.
I will not, I will not.
Let's go, thank you, welcome back!
Got 28 bucks!
It'll bring the best summer vibes in streams.
It's still summer!
Sleeping with fishes implies sleeping in a waterbed.
Waterbeds are fun.
I...
Oh my gosh.
I've only been in a waterbed once.
It was not my own.
I think it was like my aunt or something.
And I would always be like, Can I go over and lay in the
waterbed?
But like...
I can't stop thinking now about how pain in the butt it
would be to be in one.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Thank you.
In a waterbed or on a waterbed?
I guess it would... Well, I mean...
Oh...
Imagine...
Oh my gosh, wait, that would be a sick, like, crime scene.
You see the body in the waterbed.
Minto, thanks to the Agio recommendation last week, the
garlic bread was really tasty.
Oh, you went!
Oh my gosh!
Isn't it so...
Oh, God, it is so yummy!
The garlic bread!
Oh, I'm so glad you went!
There's a kitty, please rescue him.
Oh, in this game?
Okay, we will rescue him.
rescue the kitty yeah in the water bed there's a body is it
kind of I'm sure that's a detective Conan case already must
be no the Italian place in Japan yes I recommended an
Italian place in Japan that has like killer garlic bread
more like garlic loaf it's so big it's like half and one
thing about Japan too is getting a baguette is kind of is
tougher than you think a lot of bread in japan is so soft
you know what i mean what's it called agio agio but like
yeah like so much bread is soft and then you eat so much
soft bread and eventually you're like i just want a crunch a
crunch yes and sweet the garlic bread was nice baguette
bread delicious how does one wet the water bed I don't know
why are you asking me like I would know nightmare on Elm
Street 4 actually did have a waterbed death scene oh it's
it's like I you know I felt something had to have a waterbed
death scene no
Because I'm a bet wetter.
I'm a bet wetter.
I'm wetting all my beds.
Bed on it.
Bed on it getting wetter.
It won't get wetter because we're going to be in our little
boat and we're going to survive.
My rat chewed a hole in my water bed back in the 80s.
Why does that sound like such a 80s story?
No, true story, I believe you.
The wetter, the better.
The wetter, the better?
Maybe.
Unless it's...
Uh...
Some food.
Unless it's like...
Okay, well...
Maybe I do prefer...
Well, okay, not always.
everything needs to be soggy.
Not everything needs to be soggy, but I don't know.
We have this joke in Denzetsu where like, I will go get
tiramisu and I'm like, it's just not wet enough.
I need my tiramisu to be more wet.
Like, I just...
Said maybe nobody ever.
Like, I will literally, I'll get tiramisu from a nice place
and I'll be like, but the family restaurant had, like, the
family restaurant had better tiramisu for $3.
I get what you mean?
You get me!
You mean moist?
I mean, it could be.
Who said tres leches?
Good call.
I love tres leches.
Wait.
Aren't we now on ses leches?
How do you have so many leches?
How?
How do you gold from...
How do you double your leches?
Some tiramisu are way too dry.
Right!
And it's like kind of the point of it to be wet, no?
All the leeches.
We're milking every animal.
Any side...
Oh, sorry.
No, any...
Why did I say that?
Oh, any chance we're soft or wet large toast with sunny side
up eggs in the middle.
Well, why are they wet?
Your greed for leeches is insatiable.
Yeah.
Any side of eggs?
Waiter?
May I have my eggs moist, please?
She wants tiramisu soup.
That's good.
That's so good.
That's that's pretty clever.
That's pretty clever.
Wow.
Dang it.
Why didn't I think of that?
I'm gonna beat myself up tonight.
I'm gonna be like stupid, stupid.
Why?
Say slayches.
No, say s-s-s-s-say-de-laches.
No!
Wait, I just understood!
I hate it when someone's funnier than me.
Yeah.
God, I'm so stupid.
I'm so stupid.
So dumb.
Why can't I come up with any jokes?
Everybody only laughs at how dumb I am.
Not for me.
be clever.
I'm getting punched in the face right now.
You used my lack of knowledge of Spanish to get me.
You did.
You took advantage of a poor white girl.
How do you feel?
How do you feel about that?
You took advantage of me.
Punched in the face.
We laugh at your silly and celebrate your clevers.
Well, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Shall we try the game?
I'm excited to try this, but I'm also nervous.
Because I don't want to sleep with any fish.
I don't want to become that mean.
You know, did you take Spanish classes in haunting school?
Your accent is so good.
Really?
No, I actually, I took French and I
Tested to a smart school because they had Japanese
You would never know now
Yeah Thank you for being you.
It's just be my mom Brian, thanks.
That's all I know how to be is me.
Born a weeb.
No, I died a weeb.
Maybe I was born a weeb.
Born and died a weeb.
I hope that's on my gravestone.
I wonder if I have a gravestone.
I wonder if I was cremated.
Or maybe they just threw me out to sea.
And I did get slept with the fishes.
were fed and eaten upon by the fish how was studying for it
for what for the school or for French or being French
Spanish actually has a close phonology to Japanese yes I
think that's why my accent maybe is okay sent to space sent
to space thank you one oh no no no my my japanese teacher
was so funny because thank you full of sushi help yummy
cream made it and put in a tub of gamers
that's right you too can get mine ashes as the flavor my my
Japanese teacher he was really great he would he would teach
us through like songs and stuff so we would listen to like a
few songs over and over and over and over and over and over
again like multiple times every day and one of the songs
that I sing in a In karaoke, the Funky Monkey Baby song is
one of those songs.
The Miku?
No, he was like way old school.
He was like, he was...
Yeah.
Give us your best line in French.
Maybe like one of your French girls.
Gamer subs, if only there was a code for 10% off.
You can get Gamer subs!
10% off!
Boomer!
How much enka?
A little bit of enka.
Actually, we would listen to some enka.
There was another song called The Goddess of the Toilet.
Toiere no kami-sama.
It was about like cleaning your toilet every day to appease
the goddess of the toilet.
and the girl learned it from her grandma and then the
grandma dies and she cleans her toilet and thinks of her
grandma it's like a seven minute song I'll sing it for you
guys sometime listening to Japan soon do you recommend a
specific translation tool or passion Japanese I think you
could go like deep L and be very fine I hope Pinto's ashes
didn't get scattered to the heartless scene.
No, I wouldn't.
No, he wouldn't.
He wouldn't scatter my ashes to the heartless scene.
I've been thinking, oh my gosh, for unrelated, okay, well,
actually the anniversary of MGSV happened the other day, and
I was, like, watching the trailer for it, and, like,
listening to Nuclear, and, like, you know, then it's just,
like, the Phantom each letter comes in individually.
M-E-T-A-L, you know, like Metal Gear.
And I was just like, whoa, man, the trailer!
I think I like the trailer more than I like the actual game.
It's so...
I'm nuclear!
Oh.
It's such a...
It's so like...
I'm like, man.
And then you see...
And then you see like proto-rex, saw a philanthropist, and
you're like, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh man.
Mechanically, MGSV is top notch though.
I will never deny that.
MGSV is so fun to play.
Yes, of course.
Given your goal, so I take it you already failed at this
game.
What the?
No, I'm here, I'm here.
Spending another birthday with, Def Mickey!
Zubu!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy, happy, happy birthday!
My Japanese teacher was great, he taught through songs too.
He had an idea of starting a Japanese club that did
fundraisers so we could travel to Japan.
He didn't stay long though.
No!
That's so sad!
The trailers were MGS video, a big bucket of memes.
They're incredible, epic, and invigorating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, man!
Yeah.
Oh, what other song?
There was another song, Smile by Shiori.
We also listened to, which I don't think I've ever listened
to another Shiori song.
I don't even, I don't even, but it was like,
Uh, Uh, Uh, Uh, Uh,
And like, we would listen to these songs so often that like
my friends and I in the class we would get like a little
more unhinged every time.
Every time we would get a little bit more unhinged.
and so eventually like for the takara parts we would just be
like we would just like scream it we would just like look at
each other wide-eyed crazy manic like literal foam coming
out of our mouths and we'd be like i mean when you're
listening to this song every day multiple times it's like we
just we would have to yeah there was a rumor that the The
main Japanese professor at my college was teaching in
America as a way to avoid paying alimony 26 points.
How does a rumor like that get started?
You learned yakai in school?
It comes from the soul!
I gotta eat ice soup for a while after buying the recent
bundle.
Oh my gosh, Nevi, darling, thank you!
I'm sorry.
The bag is so cute.
Thank you for cute merch.
I was really happy to have something that felt like so...
Like everybody can wear it, you know?
And especially like the cardigan, I wanted it to be so cute
and like, you know...
Because I know the lighty eye booze out there.
I want them to be repping so cute.
They're already cute.
Everybody's already cute.
And also guys, if you want to wear the cardigan, you'll look
so cute too.
And it'll look awesome and everybody will be so cute!
everybody will be so cute i can't wait if you get it if not
that's okay too i know it's very expensive don't don't feel
like you have to break the bank to get but if you can get it
if you feel like getting it you'll be so cute even me even
you lady ibu and gentle ibu are you gonna be the cutest yes
Yes!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Regardless, anytime you wear any Minto stuff, will I turn
Asian if I get it and wear it?
I feel so bad.
That drop was...
That announcement was such...
I don't know what was happening to me.
It was such a mess.
practicing my kawaii for when the cardigan arrives oh oh my
gosh wait spangy it would look so cute the cardigan fits in
so well with my normal wardrobe i can't wait to see the
cardigan will make us feel bonita do you feel bonita yeah
you will feel bonita lady ibuz i feel seen
booze.
All I boo.
It took 100 seconds to make spaghetti.
Then dropped all of it.
I think, okay, I didn't say it before.
But
so basically, I don't like Peek.
I don't like that game.
game and so i was like i i we were thinking about playing
something else and then i guess i wasn't paying attention to
the group chat and they chose peak and i was like okay
that's fine um i'm not gonna fight about it you know i don't
really care but i was like i was like oh man i have to play
peak but yeah it's just like not my cup of tea but you know
it's fine i like i like to have fun with other people and so
that's kind of why i just like mess around with it um
um but i think because my brain was just like oh man i'm
gonna have to play the game no i'm gonna be like i don't
want to cure cancer i want to turn people going no sorry if
you've ever been asked this but have you watched escape from
new york i have But I have not watched Escape from L.A.
Yes, I didn't know about Snake Pliskin.
Kurt Russell.
I did, I did.
Thank you, though.
I showed my mom the sloppy university merch.
She really liked their cardigan, so I bought it for her.
Oh, wait, that's so cute!
Mama?
Speaking of merch, my spooky hunting declaration of Carol
Xandie finally shipped!
It'll be here in time for Halloween.
Maddie, I'm so sorry.
It took, like, a whole year.
Thank you, though.
Thank you for waiting.
Thank you for being paid.
I don't want to cure cancer.
I want to turn people into dinosaurs.
Agreed, agreed, agreed!
Your cells will be stronger!
I was watching a whole thing yesterday about, like, it was
talking about, uh...
Like, the true coloration of, like, T-Rexes and stuff and
different dinosaurs, because, you know, in the past Jurassic
Park they've been a given like this crocodile brown
crocodile gray greenish color you know but but just kind of
how like in reality like actuality they would be like you
know more camouflage to their surroundings and stuff and
yeah Um, there's like some...
There's some dinosaurs that...
The DNA is so well preserved that they can match it to
like...
They can match like the...
There's certain like patterns that... That when they're...
Like, I don't know scientific terms.
But you know what?
When they are...
What's the word?
In that arrangement.
They can...
They make a color.
Yeah, pigmentation, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so they, they, why am I talking about, they can match
that to birds of today.
And so, they've done that with like, some, some things where
they're, they're well preserved enough.
Melanos, melanos, melanos.
Yes.
Sorry, brain fried.
Yeah, unfortunately, there's nothing, they can't, they
haven't found any for T-Rexes yet, but there's other, like,
dinosaurs that they've been able to find it for, and they
have, like, you know, there are some that have, like,
striped tails, like, like, raccoons and red pandas.
It's molasses, yeah, it's molasses.
So it's so cool, it's so cool.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Have you seen Dino Blade, the dinosaur souls, like, I
have...
not.
Well, that sounds terrifying.
On the sloppy topic, did you happen to see their Star Wars
character?
No, I didn't!
She should have sent it to us.
Yeah, it is really cool.
Hmm.
Oh, wait, the game?
Wait, Dino, what is it?
Dino Blade?
I'm gonna look it up.
Dino Blade.
It's not too hard.
It's not.
Dino.
Opening on Steam.
Whoa!
Was that a Spinosaurus with a...
With a...
Oh yeah!
Step into the role of a young Spinosaurus wielding a
colossal giant sword!
Wait, I didn't know that you would play as the dinosaur!
I thought you were fighting the dinosaurs!
Wait, this is sick!
Wait, that's so awesome!
Oh my god!
Souls like tags.
Souls like dinosaurs.
Wait, that's so awesome!
Whoa!
I feel like...
Is the combat not really clunky?
It is quite the experience.
Sounds fine.
Dinosouls.
I'm Tim, thank you so much for the fun!
Good then!
It's pretty good actually?
Oh yeah?
Hmm.
We'll think about it.
Oh, my God.
These are crazy.
It looks fun.
Oh, wow.
It came out somewhat recently.
Came out in July.
End of late July.
But, yeah.
Have you thought about playing Dino Crisis?
I want to!
It's on my list.
It's literally, actually, I see a list.
I have a list of games just, like, that I want to start
eventually so that I can...
I don't forget because my brain is so scattered all the
time.
But, uh, Dino Crisis is on the list.
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, it is.
Hmm.
Did you see the state of play?
I didn't realize the state of play was going to be
happening, but I heard it was...
Okay.
I saw the We got a release date for Until Dawn 2.
Let's go And a release date for the new FF7
Not much new announced besides a new Konami IP.
I see, I see Caitlin I'm so ready for until dawn two i'm win
is until dawn two it's january it's so far from now i'm so
excited yeah but yeah i'm excited i want to play it that's
kind of soon it's september october november december
january for four months
Well, the Tyrannosaurus rex is called this meaning Tyrant
Lizard King, only for bigger carnivores like the
Spinosaurus, the Gettosaurus to dwarf it.
I like T-Rex though, he's so cute.
I bring the good news!
I got the job!
I'm gonna buy a pool full of high sauce!
Who wants to take a dip?
I brought my Vinky Plush for support.
Red Cog!
Roads!
I knew you'd do it!
I knew it!
Oh!
I knew it, I knew it!
Oh my gosh, wait, I've been yapping for so long.
Sorry.
I'm gonna play the game.
How do we play this game?
I'll show you guys.
I also don't know so much.
You are the captain of a ship on a covert delivery mission
with a small crew.
Without warning, something strikes the vessel, causing
severe damage.
You wait for the emergency horns.
When they sound, you know you need to evacuate immediately.
Step one, grab and run!
Time is running out!
Whatever you can and toss it into your lifeboat.
You guys got me talking about dynos.
And you got me talking about games.
And you got me talking about everything.
You're just wrecked.
And my brain is extra empty today.
There's like so many things that I'm planning right now.
So I'll like wake up and I'll have like a mental list in my
head like, okay, I need to ask so-and-so person about this.
I need to look up so-and-so thing.
write down so-and-so thing.
I need to write, I need to do this thing and send it to the
person.
That's been a busy week.
And I've been doing a lot of dance practice or something.
So...
Ah.
Yes.
So, yeah.
Sorry if I'm extra scattered this month i'd say maybe not
this month this week though this week i'm extra scattered
for real game yep i'm here for me though thank you lance oh
mental list disappears and a spinosaur takes its place
spinosaurus commit she starts coming in you know that you
know that dog that goes i just got like a little spinosaurus
in my head doing that
Make Sakana proud and yapp with the best.
What's that guy have to do with anything?
I...
Got promoted!
My Vinto.
My Vinto merch got a raise.
Want more merch raised too!
I'm in Japan on your B-Day.
Thanks for being new.
Oh, she looked good.
Wow, Bobo, let's go!
Congrats!
Bro got confused.
Under no circumstances do you gotta make Sakina proud.
I, I, yeah, I think, uh, I don't even know, like I, knows
who I am anymore.
You gotta do the opposite, right?
I guess because he's a fish.
Baby, but we're eating fish in this, right?
I mean, we got a little can of fish.
Gather whatever you can and toss it into your lifeboat.
Before the ship sinks.
Every item counts.
Escape by staying near the boat at the end.
However, it can only carry one more person besides you.
So we look around.
We wash the and we grab throw with E.
Or left click or right shift.
Survive.
Use the daytime to spend your energy on fishing.
We got three energy, boys.
I mean to find Tom.
That's me!
Thanks for the kind words, everybody.
everybody.
Yeah.
Fishing, eating, doing small tasks, or chatting to your
shipmate if you brought one.
When you run out of energy, end the day and try to sleep
hoping nothing disrupts your rest.
Step three, make choices.
If your night does not get interrupted, or if your night
does get interrupted, use an item you brought to handle the
situation.
If you have no answer, you can try going back to sleep.
Sometimes that's your only option.
The same choice may lead to different in another
playthrough.
I understand.
Let's go.
Okay, I have to be swift, right?
La la la, I'm on a boat.
La la la, beautiful day I see.
La la, nothing bad happening.
La la, life is great.
La la, the ship for you and me.
La la, everything's fun.
La la, everything's great.
are you?
I'm so short.
I want a can of one.
Sorry.
Oh, uh, cat?
Oh, no.
Grab the cat.
Oh, I can carry three things.
Oh, too heavy!
I can't carry three things!
How much time do I have?
Oh, 26 seconds?
We're good.
Oh, I can't grab three things!
I'm grabbing you!
16 seconds!
What do I have?
Food!
That sounds important!
10 seconds!
I got this, I got this.
Uh.
More bait!
I grabbed a woman.
She was the only thing I saw.
Rip that guy.
Ooh?
There was a guy?
Wow!
Look at this!
This!
Laurel is happy.
Let's see, what's our journal?
Well, there goes Dorothy!
That's my freaking Lou Goblin!
Laurel!
Yeah, Dorothy, you mean Yanny.
Yeah, guys, which do you hear?
Which do you hear?
Laurel.
I'll say it one more time.
What should you do here?
Yanni and I are the only ones left sitting in this old junk
of a lifeboat.
I have no idea what struck our ship and judging by the
sound, I honestly don't want to find out.
Now all we can do is survive as long as we need.
I'm sure help will come soon.
I'm full.
I feel healthy.
I'm well rested.
We can...
Oh, let's...
Try fishing.
Okay.
Oh, we got...
One salmon!
You know what, based on the title of the game, and men
stopped getting pregnant rant.
I was expecting a different style of game.
You need to get your head out of the gutter.
You need to get your head out of the poop deck.
That's what I say.
Write a message!
Write using your mouse.
Okay.
We'll get a reply.
Eventually.
Let's see.
Captain Whiskers!
Let me pet the...
Oh, that's some good...
That's the good stuff.
Oh, yeah.
We got a map?
Uh, duct tape.
Click to change.
Repair, our boat is good.
Let's talk to Laurel!
Hello!
You saved my life.
Thank you.
I will repay it after we you know survive but I'm sure we
will she's optimistic I love it I tried to bring some stuff
with me too but this is all I could get look oh that's huge
a life preserver nice a swim ring we love it okay time to go
to sleep why was I the only one running around why didn't
anybody do anything everybody else was just standing there
twiddling their thumbs.
Oh my gosh, Captain Wisko's...
Laurel's still happy.
I'm just...
I could eat a snack.
I'll try fishing.
Yes.
Whoa.
Nice.
A sardine?
Disgusting.
Okay.
Let's talk.
Lots of plants are actually pretty used to the harsh
environments well let's try to be like some really really
sturdy plants okay don't tell me what to do yeah first
priority feed the cat we're getting lots of food for
ourselves so nice salmon oh yum yum all right good night i
hope our night isn't interrupted Very much a codec call kind
of talk.
Choose an item.
Well, if it's raining, I'd say...
An umbrella.
Laurel, I think, is right here.
This reminds me of Chapito from Grim Fandango.
Stay away from boats when it comes to navigation.
Trust only the moon and the star.
I'm gonna
Wait, these are both Or this is sparkling Or wait, so is the
bucket Wait, I'm confused Am I gonna get electrocuted?
I sure hope not Oh, maybe we're fine
Oh I was jolted awake by the sound of thunder That followed
by the flashing lights of the storm That brewed up last
night Our boat is damaged I managed to keep myself dry with
an umbrella, though it may not have been the best idea to
use one during a storm in the middle of the ocean.
Shhh, who cares?
We're fine.
Okay, repair the boat.
Ah.
Okay.
Nice.
How'd you sleep?
Oh, she's peckish!
Why does she look like an alien?
Were you abducted last night?
Yeah.
oh I know let's try using that map we have so we can find
something that could help us could you lend it to me oh hand
over the map she seems she
seems reliable I'd say getting a feeling of deja vu luniton
episode about too hungry castaway some days ago they forget
to board the ship in excitement of seeing it and trying to
eat wait what looney tunes is this they're eating each other
in looney tunes why no trust me though no I'm gonna hand I'm
gonna give it to her I'm gonna give it to her I don't want
to be I don't want to be the one navigating it it looks like
we're way too far from any shores we're going to row for a
few days.
Wow.
Oh, we can feed her, too.
Amazing observation.
Oh, whoops.
There we go.
Amazing observation.
Laurel.
Oh, a crab!
Oh, we are eating good.
We are eating good okay good night
oh choose an item I'm nervous duct tape what if our stuff
falls out of the what if our stuff falls out of the boat oh
wait we only have the swim ring that we can use wait it will
only let us use this okay
good night we're on day four for if I fall out of the boat
something broke oh it got deflated pet and captain whiskers
behind me wait why did it my stomach my stomach's growling
you're still peckish you're fine
Her hands look infected?
I mean, what am I supposed to do about that?
The boat is still fine.
I guess we could fix it.
And we'll fish.
Oh, maybe I should have talked to her.
That's fine.
Nice.
A mackerel.
Macarrel.
Oh.
Last night was nausea.
to say the least, had I slept an hour longer, I might have
ended up under the boat.
I had a swim ring lying around so I put it on just to rest
assured I wouldn't wake up in the salty water.
That is what I did.
I would not be able to identify any fish.
That's why you're not captain of this ship.
Is it raining again?
We did the umbrella last time.
What about the bucket?
Oh!
I I thought we would be collecting the water to drink.
Not putting it on our head.
Okay, that works too.
A little rain isn't so bad.
After baking under the sun, I'm sweating for hours.
Waking up to that felt surprisingly refreshing, but I also
needed proper rest.
So I covered my head with a bucket to get some unbothered
sleep.
Okay.
I will feed you.
I will feed myself.
How are you doing?
She's happy, she's fine.
don't worry i'm not seasick i'm just emotionally wavy today
oh my god me too girlfriend i get that oh my god emotionally
wavy oh i see
yeah i get that i get that she's so real new phrase unlocks
i know I'm emotionally wavy.
How do I get more bait?
What?
I wasted a bait for a bit.
Wait, junk?
I'm not that hungry.
Wait, what's the junk junk in my trunk?
What do you call a fish with no eyes?
A fish.
I know that joke was a lot of carp.
But just remember that you can tune a guitar, but you can't
tune a fish.
Oh, wow, our night was so peaceful.
What is the junk?
I guess you eat the...
What does support mean?
Improves eating efficiency today.
I'm supporting you.
I tried seasoning today's ration with sea salt and kelp.
It should be more nutritious this way.
Oh my gosh, Laurel is awesome!
Go Yanni!
I think the sea has moods.
She was sad yesterday.
I could feel it.
I'm sad today.
Whoa, a flounder.
All right, good night.
She is an empath to the ocean.
Oh, next time we should check our boat's condition.
Check the back.
Yeah, something's behind me.
Yes.
I got a fish.
Yippee!
Okay.
I could probably eat twice.
Oh, she's hungry too.
You eat also.
And Captain Whiskers get some stuff too.
We got a fee!
Sounds of slapping and flopping filled the air last night.
I decided to investigate and find the source.
And lo and behold, somebody decided they wanted to be my
breakfast today.
There is still kindness in the rough seas.
very very interesting uh our boat we can repair it yeah you
should have ate yesterday wait why did the her salting the
food only last one day if so that's so stinky what's the
catch of day in Latin carpe diem oh the food bonus was only
that day oh my gosh no well I had no idea oh that's what it
said I didn't realize youtubers can't read I'm so sorry I
hope that they didn't think I or my hobbies were weird but
I'm sure they'd be proud of us right now we're managing
we're surviving Yanni I only have two bait left I only have
two bait left it's so bad
All right, good night.
Dang it, I'm, I'm, well, I guess I know for the future
about...
Oh.
Oh my god.
My girlfriend.
Wait.
Choose an item.
Uh.
Oh, no.
Oh, the swim ring, maybe?
They sent a picture too!
What does that mean?
So...
You're single?
I can now write him another message!
The currents guided a bottle to the boat last evening.
I wonder who sent it to the ocean.
Or when it was sent or why.
Having the paper completely blank on the other side gives me
the chance to send a message back into the waters.
Here, I'll do this, watch.
Oops, I did the hand the wrong way.
Wait.
It's fine.
That's catfishing?
Isn't that the game?
Yeah, I've been fishing this whole time.
Oh my god, we wasted...
Oh no, it didn't waste a bait!
Oh nice!
Okay, good.
Thank goodness.
This might be our last bait though.
One more bait!
But I will eat.
A lure was fine.
to need food we can just pet him and he's fine captain
whiskers peaceful night okay okay i know things in this game
can get pretty freaky pretty weird so oh wait what's that i
thought it was going to be a story of a hard-working fish
wife who yearns to leave her small fishing village and start
a new life as a singer in the big city i think i was
mistaken yeah nothing like that i don't care Yeah, yeah!
Let Laurel handle it!
Alright, go get a girl.
You got this.
I hope she's a good swimmer.
Oh!
Nice!
We got more bait!
Good job!
Good job, Laurel.
Is player characters like you?
No consistent sleep schedule.
What are you talking about?
I have a consistent sleep schedule!
Let's, uh...
Wow, we got a lot of bait!
That was awesome!
Nice.
We got...
Okay, Laurel, you get to eat.
And me too.
And I get to fish.
Yes.
Good job.
Yanny.
Are you sure?
I probably am one of the few VTubers that does have, like, a
consistent...
Click to heal.
No, I'm fine.
My boat's good too.
I'm probably one of the few VTubers that has a consistent
sleep schedule.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, I should probably talk to Laurel too.
Oh, we'll talk to her tomorrow.
My bad.
Why don't VTubers sleep?
I don't know.
Oh.
What is that?
Ew!
What is it?
Capture him!
What happened?
I...
It wouldn't let me use the umbrella.
Wait, what just happened?
What?
A small rascal found its way onto my boat and was looking
through my supplies.
With a confident throw, I managed to catch it with my swim
ring, forcing it to drop my belongings before splashing into
the water.
I wonder how that thing plans to get out of there.
And we lost the swim ring.
No, that was so useful.
No.
I...
I overslept.
So I'll think...
I can stay up this night and guard while you rest.
What do you say?
No, no, I can do it.
No.
That's fine, too.
If you insist.
No, I want to...
I'll do the night.
Don't worry about it.
We got goblins in the middle of the ocean.
Sophie Bear, I hope you're doing well too!
Thank you, welcome back!
I'll eat.
And we throw.
Very nice.
I wonder if we can get something that's more than just one
thing, you know?
More than one food.
Okay.
Peaceful night again.
Wow.
This run is so normal.
We can repair the boat.
Peckish.
Okay, we got...
I'll talk to you.
Do you want to fish more efficiently?
I could make some bait from fish.
Would that be useful?
Oh, make minus one.
Yes!
I think this will do.
We hopefully get a return on this.
Oh my gosh, Yanni is the best!
I rescued the right person, you guys.
Seriously.
That is very useful.
Yes!
Make bait from fish!
And we get a crab!
Okay, good night.
in clutch, for real.
What's going on tonight?
Flashlight!
Use the flashlight!
There's a boat over there!
S-O-S!
Keep doing it?
I think I just saw other people, and it was a huge ship,
too.
I flickered my flashlight as hard as I could, hoping to be
seen.
But they didn't notice.
To them, I was probably just one faint glimmer in the
moonlit ocean with this cheap old flashlight.
No!
Oh, why are you unhappy?
Oh, now you're happy.
I've lost track of the days we've been here already.
If only I had a way to write them down.
Why are you looking at me like that?
Because I have a journal and you don't.
That muisk was...
She hangry.
She's feeling emotionally wavy.
Or maybe they thought you were a Paul turguise.
What?
Are they have something against Paul?
People named Paul?
She also has a pencil in her hair.
Oh, no way.
Does she actually?
Oh.
Swap, wap, wap, wap.
Oh, she does, actually, yeah.
Okay, good night.
have been quite normal.
There's fish.
There's... Oh!
There's lots of fish.
They're under the boat.
Choose an item.
Do I have anything that...
Oh, let me throw out the bucket.
I hope I don't lose it.
Ha!
No!
Nice.
Where'd that flower come from?
Has that always been there?
What a fortunate night!
I woke up at just the right time to see a group of fish
circling around the boat.
So I took the chance to do some fishing.
I'm thankful for every bite I can get while sailing this old
thing.
Yeah.
Free fish.
Oh, you're awake.
Something weird happened this morning.
A seagull flew by with a flower in its beak.
Oh!
It dropped it right onto our boat.
So naturally I scraped up whatever dirt I could find and
planted it.
Look at her.
Happy as can be.
Oh, that's why we have a flower now.
What?
That should mean land is close, no?
How could she find any dirt?
How dirty is this boat?
It's disgusting.
Nice.
Okay, good night, Yanni.
Only room for one goblin.
What's that sound?
Oh, it stopped.
Hello?
E!
Um.
We can do my fish.
We can do the flashlight.
We can do the umbrella.
I feel like I don't want to give it my fish.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, throw Laurel.
Oh, Laurel's so useful.
Oh, well.
Or I could just go back to sleep.
I can't imagine what the umbrella would do.
I don't want to get...
I'm going to try the flashlight.
Maybe he'll be like...
Wow, that thing sucks!
You know...
Oh, I think we just lost the flashlight.
Oh my gosh.
What the heck?
What did we write about?
My surroundings went dead silent as it stared into my eyes
with its hollow gaze.
Without even trying to comprehend what I saw, I started
flickering my flashlight.
I had a flashlight at it, hoping the light would save me
from that stare.
It bothered it enough to make me lose the light in fear.
Wow, it's a good thing you weren't awake for that, Laurel.
Here I am going through cosmic horrors.
You're asleep.
Oh, I barely, I got no sleep because of that.
I'm gonna eat two foods and then fish.
That made me jump.
That was scary.
Rip our flashlight.
Okay, good night.
How?
Nothing.
Never come back.
It was a peaceful night.
Ah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
Yanni, go get it.
Get it, get it, get it.
Oh, wait.
Since she was heckish, though, hopefully she's alright.
Cthulhu next, right?
Right.
An energy bar.
Support.
Oh, nice.
Let's go.
I tried seasoning today's ration with seesaw and kelp.
It should be more nutritious this way.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
You two.
Everybody eat.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
We are living in luxury on this boat.
Truly.
We are living so good on this boat.
aren't we cat moiscus yeah I need a goat
let's see
I'm scared now oh it's a it's a chest like a treasure chest
sorry my head's kind of blocking it is this game dark I can
turn up the brightness too if it is yeah take the chest take
the chest am I gonna fault is it a mimic oh okay i thought
it was coming out of the water by itself
not too bad welcome wow oh it's all of our energy to open it
oh my gosh we're out of bait here i go oh it's a
Telescope!
Okay, good night.
Maybe I should have waited until she- Oh, whoops, I forgot
to read the journal.
Maybe I should have waited until she was more than peckish.
We're gonna be running low on food now.
Another night.
Another something weird.
You are unprepared?
What did- That's- that's horrifying!
What does that mean?
Oh, it's a plane.
Oh no, I don't have my flashlight!
Oh gosh, that was...
That is a horrifying message.
Good night.
Oh man.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I can't be wrong.
That was definitely not a bird.
That means people are flying over this damn sea, which means
I will get rescued eventually.
Makes perfect sense, right?
Mysterious heavy chest with no key to be seen.
Okay.
Man.
Let's fish.
It's okay you're thriving out here.
Will any fish even bite with no bait?
Oh.
We can eat this.
It is not worthless junk.
We can eat the seaweed.
What's wrong with us?
Fishlet.
Way too small.
Oh, your oral is bored.
Okay, my bad.
We'll talk to her tomorrow.
Oh!
Wait, this is awesome!
Yes, go to the island!
Oh, I could have sent her instead.
I got too excited.
Oh, my gosh.
What do we have here?
Bait!
And...
That's it.
we live here why don't we stay here on the island are we
stupid why don't we get back on the boat i found a lonely
minuscule island so i decided to take a small tour among the
shrubs i found an old cam with worms feeding on the scraps
inside we'll do for the fishies i think we're dumb
if i were a plant i'd be a dry tired tattered little shrub
barely hanging on Is it because everybody gets your name
wrong, Yanny?
Okay, she's happy now.
We're fine.
Why didn't we stay on the land?
Nice.
All right.
I'm glad the food doesn't seem to spoil.
So, like, oh, let's repair our boat.
Just in case.
All right.
They're back.
Oh, no.
Wait, what the heck?
Uh, I am unprepared.
I'm unprepared.
Bait.
There you go.
Oh.
It appeased them.
We lived!
But at what cost?
Hungry.
Unwell.
Wait, why are you unwell?
Why are you unwell?
What happened?
I overslept again.
Do you need rest tomorrow night?
I can stay up if you want.
What do you say?
No, no, no, it's fine.
That's fine too.
You're sick.
On account of not eating enough, that's not true at all.
I was greeted by countless hungry mouths, not knowing
whether they were after my supplies or me.
My only chance was to escape was to feed them.
I didn't have enough for all of them, but I tried anyway.
Throwing some bait distracted them just long enough for me
to get away safely.
For now.
We have no bait now, though.
But it's a good thing we went to that island.
Oh, geez.
Come on.
Oh!
Plastic bottle.
One second.
Convinto!
Be having a lovely week so far.
I've been having a nice birthday yesterday and gonna spend
the weekend at a local anime con.
Have fun fella!
Peaceful night.
Day 20.
Is it really?
I thought it just said day 14.
Okay, I'm gonna eat.
And I'll get the barrel.
Well, no, actually, I think we need to...
I was gonna say, I think we need to fish for more stuff.
Because it's gonna be tough fishing.
We don't get, like, a food every time, you know.
So I'll heal you.
I didn't mean to talk to you.
Oh my gosh.
I wanted you to go get this.
Yanni, go get a...
I forgot.
I didn't... I accidentally clicked talk to you.
Oh, huge!
Huge!
Oh my god, we got six bait!
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Yanni?
No, I said yanni.
I'm gonna eat.
Well, no, I'll wait.
Maybe she'll do like the...
food thing again i'll i'll i'll eat tomorrow thanks for the
raid hello kikereki kfp hi hi i'm playing this like funny
little roguelike game where you're stranded on a bow akscf2
thank you rice and glitch rice thank you oh no she's peckish
and me too all right certain things.
We can repair our boat, we can fish.
Little things happen in the middle of the night and in the
day.
Remack, thank you.
Spank a dime, thank you.
That's thank you.
Fishing roguelike, except it's not really fishing.
You quite literally, you have enough stamina to do three
things in a day.
Lunar, thank you.
Thank you, keyboard.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And we have a cat.
Basically, your ship went down.
And you could only grab a certain number of things, and now
you have to use them.
We can talk to you, Laurel.
Your face.
It tells me you know more than I do.
What does that mean?
Please, if you think you've got answers to any of this,
don't hold back.
What does that imply?
Run for rabbit, thank you.
Sisi, thank you.
Valerius, thank you.
Phil, thank you.
Visible boost, thank you.
Like 60 seconds, banana boat.
Yeah, yeah, pretty much.
From what I've been told.
Segal.
Choose an item.
Uh, what can I use?
Fish can?
The bait.
You don't want an energy bar?
I think he's going to take all...
I don't...
Okay, I have to throw a fish at him.
Thinking about doing Minto for my next Kikurumi mask.
Wah!
That'd be awesome!
Click to shoe.
Wait, now we have a pest!
One second.
Wah, wah, wah, wah, wah.
Single equals close to shore, right?
That's what I thought.
Unwell!
Why are you unwell again?
What's wrong with you?
A seagull.
I mean, it's something cute at least.
Is our cat not cute enough for you?
I think we should eat the bird.
He's kind of cute though, sitting right there with me.
No!
Ooh!
Red snapper.
for good luck i wonder what i can use the duct tape for why
are you unwell all right let's go to sleep
cool windy night choose an item uh we can choose the map or
the umbrella what's the map gonna do Oh.
I had a feeling that was going to happen.
Oh.
Yippee!
Guys, this is bad.
This is getting bad.
This is getting...
and there goes all of our bait yeah kfp raid happens in the
game we get raided by a bird and now
what do you think laurel more birds the more the merrier
they say right i think she's trying to kill us the wind blew
strongly not letting me rest if i were a little less careful
it could easily tip me off the boat and send me into the
ocean out of the situation a fish carried by the currents
flew straight into my face i can't decline any food that the
greater forces send me i don't know what to do please be a
fish bottle microplastics now where do we store those all
right let's sleep i don't know i'm gonna see i'm gonna give
it until tomorrow
The duct tape!
We're time to shine!
Nice.
Okay, surely we didn't use the entire roll for that.
Okay, still only two.
How do you feel, Captain Wisk was...
Had no high hopes for this old dinghy.
But I didn't expect a leak so big it could have drowned me
in my sleep.
I acted quickly enough to keep my boots from filling up with
water, though.
I just hope this boat doesn't hold any more surprises.
for me we're starting to run low on everything we have like
little items left we're kind of getting screwed baby we were
living in luxury until we were not uh oh my gosh why are
there so many bots today oh my goodness gracious so sorry
guys just report them just ignore them
I did.
The compass hasn't been much use, is it?
You would think that it would be a great use, no?
Like, it's a compass.
Oh, come on, we can eat that.
We can eat that.
Okay.
Big fish.
Big boot.
Big boss.
Hi, Captain Minky here with flex tape.
The super strong waterproof tape.
Sincerely patch bond seal and repair.
Pow!
Okay.
I'm sorry you're unwell, or I don't know what to do for you.
I'm gonna go to sleep now.
We're gonna go to sleep.
Oh.
Choose an item.
Uh...
We can actually...
I'm gonna use the compass.
Or the telescope?
What do you guys think?
It's kind of spooky though.
The compass?
This might help me navigate.
Are we even going anywhere though?
Are we even like trying to get to a certain...
Like way?
Is it helping?
Oh good job
I could barely see the end of my own boat The man in the fog
Wait I think I saw a person without a head I did not see
that Wait Huh?
I didn't see that Did you guys?
I spent so much time staring into the fog Trying to
understand where I was that May have started seeing figures
in it Vicky?
Maybe I thought we used the telescope instead okay we got a
fish be my good luck bird pat the good luck bird bird for
good luck squawk oh nice that's a fish you worthless
worthless bird okay she's still happy so we're not gonna
talk to her okay oh my god it's so over for us you guys oh
it's so over for us Did we hear Enka in the distance, right?
Ah, we got every single worthless item in a row.
Mm-hmm.
Peaceful.
No, no, I want something to happen.
So that we can get more supplies, maybe.
Support.
Yes, oh my gosh.
Yes, thank you.
More nutritious.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh.
Wait, did we lose two energies?
Laurel, the goat.
We got a fish.
Yes, yes, Laurel.
How did she heal herself, too?
Okay.
Our boat is fine.
We don't need the energy just yet.
Oh my gosh.
You woke up with just two.
That's strange because it was a peaceful nut.
What is that on the moon?
I think this might be...
Maybe...
I'm scared.
Is this a bad idea?
What the heck?
No more singles though.
What if we write about that?
I need to keep my eyes closed.
I need to keep my eyes closed, I need to keep my eyes
closed, I need to keep my eyes closed, I need to keep my
eyes closed, I need to keep my eyes closed, I need to keep
my eyes closed, I need to keep my eyes closed!
Freaking!
Only one stamina today.
But we got a fish!
Holy good luck!
Oh my gosh!
Alright, goodnight.
Oh my goodness.
What was that?
Going this way seems dangerous.
There was a thing over there.
We could try sleeping, honestly, but let's try the compass.
Do we know how to use this thing?
Like, real question.
Okay.
We, a third boat, our third bird has joined the boat.
We have, we have acquired a third bird.
I am quite nervous.
I'm quite nervous.
Wait, now I'm getting nervous.
You're bored!
Don't be bored.
Let's talk.
I'm so sorry.
I cannot believe that board is a status condition on this
thing like and also that like what are you what are you
expecting you're you're stranded in the middle of the ocean
when i was a kid my friends used to whisper rumors about the
sea one of them mentions something called the heart of the
sea i think they said it could save you from certain death i
don't buy it i'd still like to have one
as much as i would like to fix our telescope Okay, wait.
We'll do this.
We'll fix it.
Energy bar.
Fish.
Because I think fishing is also.
Being bored can be dangerous in a survival situation.
Oh my gosh.
I mean, yeah, but like...
Maybe if I'm like the world's worst introvert ever.
Like talking to someone.
I have three...
I have three spoons and talking to someone takes one of
them.
Like...
Peaceful night.
Oh, my journal.
Sorry.
I'll read it today.
The end?
Wait, what?
Seagulls!
Sleeping with feathers.
Make too many friends.
No!
Run was so good, though.
Laurel's fate is unknown.
Captain Whiskers may wander the sea alone.
No!
This is why, by law, all survival kits include MTG cards.
Wait, really?
That's crazy.
Play in Magic the Gathering at sea?
Oh my god.
Screw you!
Let's try again.
Okay, new game.
Oh!
Drowning.
No, no.
I still want to do adventure.
We're fine.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
We're going to pick up so many things this time.
Again.
Okay.
I got kidnapped.
They took my bones.
Wait.
Was that guy there before?
This guy?
Were you there?
Who are you?
Oh.
All right.
Things go wrong.
Grab the cat first.
Grab the cat.
He's right there.
Oh, there we go.
Uh, food.
Bait.
Important, important, important.
Uh, more bit, more food.
More food.
Uh, health kit.
Oh, shoot.
I don't have hands.
Ah!
Duct tape.
Message in a bottle.
Did that even do anything?
I don't know.
I got 20 seconds.
A gun!
Oh my gosh, we got a flaring gun.
Oh, I need a person.
Uh, I got a person.
Um, more food.
Oh, it's too heavy.
I can do it.
Oh, is that an anchor?
Uh, anything else?
Bait, bait, bait, bait!
Oh.
I got greedy.
No, my flare gun.
My flare gun!
Uh.
That's me!
My fate.
Sleeping with the fishes.
Oh, I was so close.
I sunk with the ship.
They survived.
Recovery efforts failed.
Ah!
I guess yeah, the captain did go down.
Right?
That's what you're supposed to do.
A good captain goes down with their ship.
Except me.
Our captain is the cat.
And that guy does not go anywhere except by my side.
What if you put everyone on the boat but yourself?
I think you can only fit one person on a boat at a time.
Wait, where's my cat?
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Oh, I see Captain Whiskers.
Okay.
Captain Whiskers in sight.
Alright.
Whoa!
Grab it, grab it, grab it!
Grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it!
Please, please let me grab things!
Please let me grab things.
Uh, hands full?
Uh, grab Mr. Whiskers?
Captain?
Captain, please?
Yes.
Oh, scuba set, can't take.
Oh.
Whoa, fishing net!
That'd be huge.
I don't have a lot of food.
That's my issue at the moment.
I do not have a lot of food and bait.
Oh, bucket can't take.
Uh.
Alright, uh, whoever you are, come here, Frederick.
My first mate.
Uh, bait, food.
Uh, eight seconds left.
Some food here.
Food.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, dang it!
Oh, my goodness.
Okay, okay.
I don't even know what I grabbed.
I wanted the scuba set.
Hey there.
Frederick?
I hope you picked me, bud.
I can steer this thing till we find someone to help us.
Don't worry.
What do you mean I hoped you picked me?
Wait, I hoped you picked...
Oh, I...
Like, maybe I had hoped you'd pick me.
right also look what i have brought with me you can have it
bud here oh flashlight thanks actually that was that worked
against that giant creature so if we get that again
Frederick and i oh there goes dorothy Frederick and i are
the only one sitting on this junk of a lifeboat all right
well captain whiskers is here too we got six food um nine
bait
okay i guess dorothy is our ship huh hmm dorothy somewhere
over the rainbow
seagulls fly his why are you staring at his crotch to ask if
his his pants have two buttons why are you staring at
Frederick's crotch, huh?
Are you into him?
Is he your type?
A lot of fun in this are the different outcomes to the
events.
I hope you survive this, Captain.
We'll survive!
This is the run.
Right, Captain Wiskas?
Blue seagulls fly over the rainbow.
We got a can of worms!
We got more bait for fishing!
Why?
Oh, I can't
That was the song my mom used to sing to me when I was going
to sleep.
See, it's probably just testing us or messing with us for
fun.
Let's see who gets the last laugh.
How'd you like that pipe?
Ha, ha, ha, ha.
It's me.
Same?
Yeah.
Oh, okay, good night, Frederick.
I miss Laurel.
I wonder what special technique Frederick has.
Oh, I need to turn.
Okay.
Uh...
We can go left to the evil moon that jump scares you?
Or right into the ship graveyard?
Somewhere over the mountain.
Rainbow seagulls fly Wave my bones as they carry them
Through the endless sky Right?
Okay.
High risk, high reward.
That's how it always works.
Right, everybody?
Also, if there's a sign in the middle of the In the middle
of the ocean, shouldn't that mean We are close to land?
No?
The boat arrived at a fork in the waterway.
I had hoped I could simply keep rowing forward but in the
end, I had to make a choice.
I turned right.
I trusted the dangerous waters more than the empty horizon.
Please don't sleep with too many fishery.
I'm not.
Honestly, I didn't sleep with them.
I got taken away by boards.
Over the rainbow always makes me tear up.
I know it's one of those types of songs, right?
How you doing, Frederick?
Say what you will, but nothing beats the taste of Sierra in
the morning.
of mind so true this guy's such an optimist also we only
have great people on board
nice a mackerel all right let's sleep yeah i like him too it
was your wedding song i can't sleep well that's it just
having a restless night we could use the umbrella or the
swim ring We'll use the...
Or the flashlight?
What's the flashlight gonna do?
I'm curious.
Oh.
What?
Reminds me of a different song.
Little boy.
Fishing off a wooden pier.
Come fish.
Bite fish.
Swim along here.
I don't know that one, I think.
Wait, what the heck did that do?
Oh, you're hungry?
Nightlight, maybe?
but we had the moon usually i'm not scared to sleep in the
dark but you never feel safe in the middle of the ocean so
as extra security i improvised a nightlight out of my torch
i just hope those small batteries last a few more days days
i don't know i feel like if i'm stuck at sea i feel like i'm
gonna be out there for like months are you secretly a pro
wrestler yeah not secretly chowder clip where he's in a boat
going down a river and says, I don't trust that sun and the
sun pulls out a club.
Quite literally the same thing here.
All right, let's just keep fishing.
Lots and lots of fish, lots and lots of fish.
And cans of worms!
Let's go.
I feel like being stranded in the ocean is the most
terrifying place to be stranded.
Like, so much can go wrong.
I guess you could eat fish if you can catch them.
If you find a way to catch a fish, you can eat it.
There's so many things that would probably take down your
boat.
You can't drink the water.
The only good thing is it's an open toilet.
That's about it.
Space would be scarier.
I mean, if you're in space, you're just...
If you're stranded in space, you're kind of screwed.
You're peckish.
Do you get hungry fast or something?
This place is way too quiet.
You know, my sailor's guts telling me we're drifting towards
danger.
Alright, buddy.
Well, drift us away.
You're the one that said you would navigate, okay?
He's a growing boy.
Sardine.
Keep it on.
An open toilet with no toilet paper.
Do you need the toilet paper?
It's also a bidet.
I think Stranded SC is like having every phobia wrapped into
one scenario.
It is...
I mean...
To be fair, do you want to be stranded anywhere?
Oh, it's the rough night again.
Uh...
Choose an item.
I guess the swim ring is our only option, right?
Oh yeah, but we broke it last time.
I remember.
You can choose not to choose but I guess if you what if
you're like like what if it's one of those things where am I
okay I feel sick last night was nauseating to say that he
said I'd slept an hour longer I might have ended up under
the boat well the boat is damaged oh shoot yeah hey
Frederick Frederick doesn't okay Frederick go get the crate
Nice.
Okay, it didn't break.
Awesome.
I can heal.
I'm too sick to...
Okay, Frederick, someone else needs to take over fishing.
I'm sick as a dog here.
Come on!
Oh, my gosh!
I don't think that wastes a bait, luckily, but...
Nice.
A red snapper.
We'll see if time heals all wounds, right?
So we'll see.
Here, I'll talk to you too.
If you choose not to decide, you still have made a choice.
Rip Neal.
Wait, oh no!
Next time we get stranded, I'm bringing a deck of cards and
a lot of beer.
Yeah, maybe I should have done the cards.
I don't think we had cards on my ship, though.
Okay, Frederick.
on today just some rain choose an item I think we oh I don't
have a bucket this time all we've got is the umbrella that's
fine just a little light rain oh the sound is nice
the sound is nice oh I'm very hungry alright
let's fish mmm
okay we'll just Keep pushing, keep pushing.
I wonder how many days, like, you're expected to go for, you
know?
We've got 12 foods, so I think I can afford to eat another
one.
Good night!
Oh, we did, yeah, we were cured.
It just took one day.
It just took a little nap.
There's a fish behind us.
Yes, yes, check the back.
It's a fish!
Oh.
Wait, what?
What?
But I heard it behind me.
Wait, what?
I decided to investigate and find the source.
Couldn't find anything.
What made that sound?
I was hoping at least for a fish that made it onto the boat.
Then I could have had a fresh breakfast!
What just happened there?
Oh, support.
Keep bait when fishing today.
That's huge!
I'll make sure those baits stay put no matter how big the
fish gets.
Oh my gosh.
we're gonna energy bar this we're gonna energy bar this
blue-footed boobies what is that it's likely you're near the
galapagos galapagos islands oh it's a type of bird the
filter didn't let me i wonder why the filter didn't let you
do that the blue-footed booby Whoa!
Plus two food with the squid!
Okay, energy bar!
I will eat though.
Alright.
Nice!
Oh my gosh, we're getting so much food.
This is sick.
It's just a bird!
Do you hate entomologists?
Aw, what a waste.
YouTube!
It's a bird!
It's not real blue-footed boobies.
Broken compass looks... Wait, what the heck?
Wait, but where's our endless food supply?
supply oh my god that was such a freaking waste no way i
used my thing and i didn't get anything
oh ornithologist that's
the study of birds oh it's this little oh my gosh let's get
this guy out of here i don't want to break my nut I'll break
the swim ring on you.
Oh, you was trying to steal my flare gun!
Oh, entomologist studies bugs.
Oh, gosh.
I knew that.
Compass is a compass.
We did get the compass.
And we do have a lot of food.
Maybe I'm being greedy.
How's it going?
I just remembered.
I have me cigar box with me.
We could send a message in it, couldn't we?
Well here goes nothing.
Oh!
I hope it finds someone.
Then returns it, of course.
It's my cigar box.
Okay, awesome.
How do you send him a message in a cigar box?
I'm not quite sure.
Maybe they scribbled onto the box.
Hey!
More bait.
We'll take it.
Good night.
More bird names are bad.
Like the little teeth and stuff.
There's like little tit birds and stuff.
Wait, did we already get a message back?
Get it, get it, get it!
The fish did!
Nice!
What's that mean?
That was an anglerfish?
That one was strange.
that was ominous we do have a flashlight he brought one for
the for the angler fish so very good minky cute text no
shane thank you so now we have the item the message in a
bottle what should we write what should we write guys tell
me i'll write what you guys think is the best way to get
people to come and save our ship
I mean if only there was like a message that meant like help
our ship like if only there was a message that said like
save us please you know if only there was a thing that like
subscribe to Bridgefront Home
ASL I already did that I already did that wait I have an
idea
I have an idea I got a reference for it and everything.
How's that?
Whatever could you mean?
You couldn't possibly mean this photo?
Maybe some KFP that I've never seen this photo.
This is how squirrels greet each other.
They are so cute.
Take down the Mona Lisa and put that in its place.
They are so Passionate and they grab each other's faces and
give a big smooch.
This seriously every time I see it it looks like a
Renaissance painting to me It is so there's every everything
about it just It's so good Oh,
it's so good It's so passionate Amazing She have the image
saved on her PC Yeah We got a card, we got a card.
Normie's flexing their relationship, those.
Can we have this photo up on the next merch announcement?
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
My game.
What is- Thank you.
Newspaper.
Say right.
Welcome to the bamboo shop.
Thank you.
Does it get tiring being the absolute goat all day, every
day?
What is that?
HSD filed for bankruptcy death responsibility is this the
company we worked for have you heard about prairie dogs they
do a mouth fight for dominance looks like they're making out
no way no way a mouth fight huh that's what they're calling
it nowadays.
Yeah, humans do that too.
Oh, the ship!
The ship!
You guys!
Do we do the flare gun?
Do we save it for the...
Let's do it.
Please!
Help us!
Why is it going all the way over there?
Are they coming?
Can you draw Spider-Man and the dino guy smooching?
Help made me on the way!
I think I saw...
Yeah, I fired my flare in the only...
My only flare in the direction, hoping to finally be saved.
They didn't so much turn, but it kept moving on.
Maybe they'll send someone instead, right?
But...
But it said help might be on the way.
So...
Make sure those baits they put no matter how many fish okay
nice marmots kiss when they fight i maybe i don't know i'm
oh no no i'm unfortunately not um so you know well versed in
every animal that kisses
please be a fish
screw it we want the we want the food we want the food Why
not?
I will look into this.
I will look into this and I will become an expert on every
animal that kisses each other.
Oh, screw you and your worthless junk.
Petting Captain Whiskers for good luck.
Squid, squid, squid, squid, squid, squid, squid, squid,
squid, squid, squid, squid.
Good enough.
Okay, good night.
I was wondering if I should save the flare for the...
plane oh oh let's use let's use our net let's use our net
how many did we get oh i see three fish that's huge all
these animals are like one two three four i declare a kissy
war oh what a fortunate sight i woke up yeah yeah okay three
fish god that's awesome He'll keep the bait again!
Maybe try the flashlight on the plane this time.
Oh, that's a good idea.
That's a good idea.
Yes, yes, yes.
Pac-Roe.
I'm going fishing in your mouth.
what
was i doing sleeping good night so passionate just call me a
squirrel
or a prairie prairie dog that was oh you're bored i won't
let it happen
we need a new name for this dingy we're on how about the
brown floater the bloater for short of course i'm open to
better names though taishkaru no it was for dominance it was
for dominance not the bloater we're on the brown i don't
know which is worse actually i think the brown floater is
probably worse
I think the brown floater is pretty bad.
I think Captain Whisker...
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, I don't have enough to repair my boat!
Uh-oh, I was just thinking.
It's been a while since I've repaired my boat.
Uh-oh, I completely forgot about it.
Yeah, have we repaired the boat recently?
Oh my god, Chris, you're thinking exactly like me.
Oh, shoot.
We have so much food.
It's awesome.
But, um...
She got that prairie dog in her.
Uh-oh.
Wait, is this the giant anglerfish?
This is the same sound as before.
Should be doing a lot of kiss in this stream.
It is, it is, it is!
Wait, but I lose the flashlight when I do this.
Oh no.
I lose the flashlight.
Ah.
Fish?
Yeah, we'll try the fish.
Here's a little freshy, freshy little baby.
That is sufficient.
Nice.
Okay, we only lost two.
Okay, good.
He is appeased.
I knew it wanted to feast.
With a shaking hand, I picked up some cans my boat and tried
offering fish to it.
If I hadn't done that, I probably would have become its
supper.
Alright, let's fix our boat up.
Sufficient.
Thank you, thank you.
Support.
Oh, no.
We have no more.
We will have no more.
No!
We have none.
To fish.
Let me try fishing.
What if we get a, what if we get like an energy bar?
Because if we get an energy bar, then we could just do it.
Oh, come on.
Energy bar.
Oh, a cod.
Cod blocked.
Okay, that's fine.
Good night, Frederick.
On the third run, try using the net on the angler.
You won't be disappointed.
Really?
Oh!
A ghost!
Hello, fellow ghosts!
Hi there!
Wow!
These seeds do be haunted.
Wait, is there whispering?
Oh!
Um...
What if I just went to sleep?
I'll try.
I had a feeling it was coming.
Ah, man.
I didn't sleep very well.
Return to Slab.
Or suffer my curse, Captain Whiskers.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't realize that.
I only had one.
I want to see the face of the guys who got us into this
mess.
The only thing we know about him is that he calls himself
the contractor.
What a weird guy.
Wait, we're getting some lore.
Okay, so there's a weirdo guy named the contractor.
What kind of ocean is this?
This is literally why Solacistophobia exists.
Wow!
Everybody be afraid.
I think I might get struck by lightning though, right?
If I use the umbrella.
I'll try it again.
I'm testing fate.
Oh, the journal!
Oh, sorry, I'll test.
I'll not test it.
I'll check it.
Hmm.
Look great!
Oh, our umbrella is broken.
A shiver ran down my spine.
Was it a lucid nightmare?
Did I actually see?
Ghost?
I grabbed my flashlight and flickered it at them to see if
they'd react.
By morning, I woke up drenched in sweat.
This place is starting to wear down my mind.
Captain Minto, I forgot my umbrella on the boat.
Can we share?
Just this once.
All right, Frederick.
Frederick, I choose you!
Fetch!
Fetch boy, fetch!
Nice.
I wonder if there's like a, like something that, is there
like a plus to getting the item, like the crates myself
versus them getting it?
You know what I mean?
I wonder.
we can fix our torn umbrella so let's let's fix it let's fix
it it's good to have and we'll fish yeah maybe the wicked
witch put a contract on contract hit on Dorothy oh my god
the contractor goddess Dorothy's confused oh wait anglerfish
was female male anglerfish are smaller lacking in lights and
often reduced to a pair of balls attached to the female
anglerfish There's no way!
And what can we say, ladies?
It's just not the much prettier.
Is the flashlight intact?
It is, it is.
Honestly, we sure...
For somebody who, like, just kind of sits...
I mean, I guess...
When you sit in the heat, it is pretty, like...
Draining, right?
Oh.
Oh, the...
the animalistic urge to use the telescope.
No.
I will use the umbrella.
I want to, I want to, I want this run to continue, you guys.
And the worst she can say is no.
Puts up an umbrella and goes back to sleep.
That scared me.
Oh my god.
did not sleep very well and she was very mean to our I can't
repair the boat I think I have to use the energy bar oh
shoot what a terrible time to have our support okay eat fish
then we'll use the energy bar okay energy bar repair dang
what does the journal say thank you guys for reminding me
about the journal I forget to click on it sometimes okay
nice it says I saw someone stranded on a rock at the
distance before I could even question it I started hearing
this weirdly calming serene melody the boat was damaged 53%
it's a good thing we fixed at that time to be fair that
siren totally got out shown by something this comforting had
to be a trap I thought I refused to listen by morning it was
gone maybe it thought I disliked its songs we fished so I'll
talk to Frederick you know I've been wondering why did this
company offer such a high payout for us they had to know the
risks right where we like was us getting shot down like part
of the company's plan Was it insurance payout?
Or were they testing, like, some sort of new technology that
targets boats?
We got a...
A crate.
A chest, yes.
Hmm.
It's all a conspiracy, yeah.
What happened to the ship?
It...
We don't know exactly.
It just, like, gets hit by something and, like, starts
sinking.
So we don't really quite know what happened to it, actually.
I'm going to open it.
Oh, a map!
Can you use that?
Frederick?
Okay, good night.
What if it's a mimic?
I thought that the same...
Same time, too.
The same thing last time, too.
A peaceful night?
Okay.
What night are we on anyway?
19 okay okay I guess
we'll go fishing how much to do you've got more chest than
Doki bird yeah whoa whoa whoa I mean I have a chest Doki
catching strays I think the last round we made it to day 30
before we got seagulled.
No!
Okay.
We have three bait left.
You liked my post on Twitter when I was in Japan, so I'm
here to brag and say you're my favorite.
Thank you!
Oh, there we go.
It glitched out for a second.
Thank you for the super chat!
A wallet!
Still has a card.
It's from HSD.
Captain!
Dough.
Durand Durand.
It says Captain of...
I think that says Dorothy, you know?
Is this us?
We found our wallet!
Woohoo!
Thank goodness, I guess.
Damien also?
Maybe.
Right now.
Oh.
Sharks.
Oh, sharks.
Uh.
Rotro.
Um.
Was that a hand?
Wait, what?
There was a skelly hand on that one?
Wait, there's...
Wait, what?
You are unprepared!
Oh!
No, no.
Shirley, bait.
No, nothing.
Nothing?
07, everybody.
07.
Whoa!
I lived?
I was so loud.
I feel weak.
Finns emerge from the water, roaming alarmingly close, but I
felt safe in the boat, or so I thought.
These were no ordinary sharks.
One of them grabbed me by the calf with its Hand?
Took a huge bite out of it!
It's still bleeding, but at least I won't need to walk for a
while anyway.
Uh...
Oh yeah, I have some pain!
Oh my gosh!
I guess let's heal then.
Um, our boat is also in bad condition.
Uh...
Soul repair.
Gosh, every time he has support, we get some stupid...
event that that knocks the boat all around it makes it bad i
almost said knock the boat up oh my gosh no it doesn't do
that our boat is not pregnant
it's infected we gotta amputate how many we got 12 fish
still three bait let's just fish
Congrats, it's a boat.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, what a, what a, what a.
I'm just going to go to sleep.
What a bad day.
Oh, that's a hand.
That's another hand.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
Make an offer?
Telescope.
See you.
You're bored.
Weeks.
I smell like aged tuna that's been thrown up.
Twice.
Just how much longer do we have to keep fighting, bud?
I don't know, man.
I don't know.
That one was fun.
Oh, the journal!
Yes.
What a...
emerged from the sea its open palm facing me it looked as
though it was asking for an offering something from my boat
for some reason i trusted it and felt that my offering would
not go unanswered i did luckily i received something in
return was it a good deal it was not the greatest deal but
it was fine i suppose food is quite valuable so
can i captain whiskers the days are short aren't they yeah
it was a deal could you have offered junk i don't oh yes yes
yeah i wonder if i'll go making frederick go instead makes
it so that i don't lose uh oh lose like oh watch your head
that can kill you for real
stamina in the morning oh my gosh wait okay why don't we eat
the coconuts take the coconut and eat the coconut you did
not sleep very well we did get a coconut yeah it's awesome
okay so maybe that's it I found a lonely minuscule island
someone must have been there before because I found an old
wooden chest.
I took it with me back to the boat.
It was so heavy and exhausting to carry.
So it better be worth it.
Interesting.
You know what, sure.
Let's keep our bait.
We're running low, so...
Uh...
We'll fish.
Hmm.
I think we should have just stayed on the island.
It's free food.
Oh my god.
What a waste of my time.
Waste of my afterlife.
I'm going to sleep.
Coconut gives energy?
Oh, does it?
It's the plane!
Flashlight, flashlight!
I don't know, right?
I'm worried that Bryce was pregnant.
Thank you for all the super chats.
Thank you so much.
Wait, did that say help might be on the way?
If only we had the flare, right?
Oh, it does give energy.
it does.
Okay, good to know.
Hungry.
No, hungry.
No more.
I can't be wrong.
That was definitely not a bird.
I hope I made enough effort to be noticed.
If someone up there saw me, rescue could only be days away,
right?
Man.
Let's open this chest.
What if it had a flare in?
Oh, hey!
The sea taketh and the sea returneth.
Very nice, sir.
Tell us scope came back.
Imagine if I had the flare, though.
I think I would have jumped overboard for real.
It's back!
Um.
Well, uh, good night.
At least we tried with the flashlight.
We tried.
Oh, right.
Going this way seems dangerous.
I tried the compass last time.
Let's try the map this time.
Hmm.
This might come in handy.
Yes.
Hmm.
It's called Friendly Cove.
Forward.
Looks like the flare gun is the only way to signal the
plane.
Maybe.
Potentially.
Looking at my surroundings, it was clear I need to navigate
a bit.
Or the boat might drift into water.
It's more dangerous than I could handle.
Truth be told, I have no idea where I'm headed.
It's more pleasant than wherever I woke up last night.
Yeah.
Let's have a snack.
You're peckish too.
Oh gosh, we're almost out of bait though.
This is it.
This is the last bait.
Our last fishy fish.
Okay.
Pet Captain Whiskers for good luck.
Oh my gosh, it worked, it worked!
fish kitty for luck kitty for luck
that's okay
I'll wait until you're hungry mister good night is the boat
repaired should be fine I'll check it though peaceful night
okay good good yes yes yes day 25 oh Oh, 79%.
Yeah, we can
repair it.
Never-ending cruise, guys.
This is so nice.
You're bored.
I can't believe we're already on day 25.
At this rate, I might just grow my hair back.
He's funny.
I like Frederick.
Okay.
Yoki.
Guys, I'll be right back.
I gotta go to the little ghosty's room.
I'll be right back.
I'm also gonna get more water.
Water, please.
Water, water.
I'm getting hungry, you guys.
I'm getting hungry.
What should I have for dinner?
For now, I'm gonna have some pretzels.
One second.
I'm getting hungry, though.
Just four.
Just four, just four.
Okay.
It's a...
Ow.
Lucy!
Yum!
Let's go sleep.
What's going on?
Is that a dead guy?
Wait, I think my head just completely blocked this guy.
Look!
We got a...
Wait a second.
Wasn't there a French guy on our...
He's the guy with the peg leg.
Should you take a look?
Or you should take a look.
He's missing a leg.
Damien.
Is that guy just behind me now or...
his idea that we had
something stuck struck the side of the boat waking me up I
pulled it on board human remains old just bones now but the
hat was still intact and stitches inside of it was the name
Damien but how the bones float don't don't worry about it
don't worry about it we're out of we're out of fish bait
we're not out of food though We've got a little bit ways
until that.
It's going to be rough, though, without bait.
Oh, yeah, let's see if the journal has any of the stuff that
we picked up.
No, it doesn't look like it.
Oh, that's kind of lame because I want to see the...
It'd be nice to see, like, the license we picked up in the
newspaper, too.
Damien's hat helped it float.
here.
Oh, that salt made him floaty.
Nice.
Is the support dependent on us having minimum one bait?
I'm not sure.
Oh.
Another boat!
Oh my god.
This is all I have.
Please!
Help!
Name of the entry was Mirror.
Maybe the name is Dame- Maybe our name is Damien too.
My fate?
It worked!
Oh my god!
We got found!
It worked!
Frederick was also saved!
Caspian Whiskers is safe!
Yeah!
Oh, look.
Pay back your debts.
Bring exploration tools.
Make yourself visible.
We got survived.
Seagulls.
Got kidnapped.
Wait, I thought I got kidnapped by seagulls before.
Sleep with the fishes.
Sank with Dorothy.
Be a bad fisherman.
I guess that's if you starve to death.
Make bad choices.
Hmm.
Wow.
Maybe by a siren.
Yeah, maybe something like that.
We could do!
Oh wait, there's lore.
Oh, here we go.
Yeah, he's the guy that's licensed for sure.
Survival expert, Minto.
Easy one would be the fishing.
True, true, true.
Let's play one more one more one more thing.
We can try a bunch of different choices this time we won't
bring frederick unfortunately we'll bring somebody else i
never survived this so congrats cap no way really i thought
the guy that washed up was that guy right there him i
thought i guess he's not french okay yanni we got a bunch of
stuff in here we're okay captain whiskers is over here yeah
captain don't worry my captain i've got you
I've got you, my captain!
My captain!
Captain, captain, my captain!
One second, captain!
Oh, shoot.
Too heavy.
Captain, captain, my captain!
Heavy.
Here, we'll bring this guy.
Thank you.
Let's go get Mr. Whiskers.
Whiskers, Whiskers, Whiskers, Whiskers, Whiskers, Whiskers,
Whiskers, Whiskers!
Uh, what else is around?
A harpoon gun!
That sounds huge.
Grab it, grab it, grab it, grab it.
Oh shoot, dang it, dang it, dang it!
I can get it!
I can't get it.
Ah!
Probably for the Shorks, maybe.
Ugh.
I got stuck on the dang barrel.
This guy looks like a poet.
Look at her, look at her.
She is the captain now!
why did you choose me okay Virgil whatever look we might end
up using this take it oh thank you for the umbrella row and
I are the only ones left sitting in this old junk row row
isn't it funny your name is row and you be you oh my gosh I
only have six bait and six food this is so bad your name is
row and you end up working on a boat It's like fade or
something.
Row, row, row.
You're about.
I bet he's never heard that one before.
All right.
Well, good night, bro.
Is this happy?
This is your happy?
Good night, Captain Whiscus.
It's never getting old, yeah.
He probably loves that joke.
He's like, yeah, yeah.
That's literally my...
That's why I came up with that song, actually.
I'm the one who rose the...
the boat what's up with you what's your thing we are far
from shore the silence is louder than a loaded gun no one
will hear us here most likely i don't why would you say that
no one will hear you scream i want to keep talking to him i
want to learn no more lore the ocean do not mistake calm for
safety that's how people disappear i want to know more lore
you know i want them like Unfortunately, Yanni said, like,
nothing.
Oh, my gosh, a plastic bottle!
I'm going to sleep.
Good night.
He's going to kill us in our sleep.
I know, right?
I wonder, is it just the three of them we could pick up?
I'm just going to sleep.
Whoa, it's the worst that could happen.
Something broke?
How did my...
How did my anchor break?
Are we for real?
I had to decide between placing my supplies the bottom of
the boat or taking that spot for myself so I could get some
restful sleep without the wind blowing into my face.
Are we for real right now?
From the wind?
I'll screw you.
Good night.
Screw you game.
There better be a fish behind me.
behind me.
Fish!
Yeah!
Yeah.
What do we think Rowe's ability is?
I don't know.
Maybe we've had maybe like healing?
Because Yanni can make bait.
Well, I don't know.
Maybe it's another thing with bait, actually.
Zareko!
Welcome back to Anki!
Thank you so much.
Oh, makes repairing less demanding today.
So, need help dealing with the damage?
All right, I'll lend you a hand.
Now get to work.
Oh, now we can fix our stuff.
Oh, I should have waited on the anchor then.
Okay.
Oh, that's not so bad, actually, because it only costs one.
And this usually costs two.
Oh.
That's not bad.
at all he learned the blade oh my gosh are we for real
please please i i'm using bait why am i not catching fish
thank you this is pretty bad though we don't have a lot i'll
feed you it's fine we're just kind of going for whatever on
this run i just want to get new stuff you know
Oh my gosh.
Choose an item.
Oh, I do have duct tape.
Kind of makes me mad that filling up this hole, though, uses
the entire role of duct tape.
I made a promise to protect them.
I failed.
The least I can do now is not give up on them.
Who's them?
Who is it?
Who are they?
Sleeping you might have given you an there that's so true I
guess if we wanted to start again this is such a I don't
know why my luck this time is so bad with with uh fishing
the sea take it in the sea give it we got do we got a duck
tape oh I guess I can use it on the on an item too It looks
like...
Oh, interesting.
The journal.
Oh, my bad.
I think it was fine, though.
It was just...
It's all stuff that we've experienced already.
Use it on row.
I'll tape his mouth shut.
Yeah.
I'll fish.
Thank you?
I don't know.
I feel like this is not a good thing.
good run though.
Thank you so much for that super time!
Thank you!
Sitting and staring out on this boat is rather boring for
you too, I assume.
But if you start singing a sea shanty, I will personally
abandon ship.
Oh my god, I thought he was... Roll, roll, roll, roll your
boat.
Gently, gently down the stream.
Barely, barely, barely, barely.
Life is but a dream.
Oh, screw you.
I wish I could use my umbrella on you.
I whack you in the face, you stupid bird.
I've got nothing.
You are robbing a poor man, you know.
You can get fish from anywhere.
Where's the harpoon gun?
So true.
Get away.
You're hungry?
Me too.
Frederick was great at giving directions.
He would have definitely sped up getting us home.
Oops.
Wait, flashlight was an option?
Was it?
I don't...
I may have made...
a new friend no it is evil evil evil
yeah we already got a bad ending from the seagulls before
unfortunately whoa tuna plus tuna plus tuna let's go nice uh
oh oh plus two now plus two oh my god we got two plus two we
got four and oh so lucky so lucky wow wow wow okay good
night why doesn't mr whiskers eat the seagull i ask the same
thing peaceful night okay like they say with friends like
these I didn't even get to do anything.
No freaking...
I guess I'll use the telescope.
Unless the flashlight...
Wait, is that...
Wait, it says that we see a guy with no head.
I want to see it though.
That was super unlucky of me.
Did you see it?
I think I saw a person without a head.
I didn't see it either.
Our guy is really going crazy.
Oh my gosh, I can't believe I wasted that day.
That's so bad.
I guess let Ro handle it.
Hmm.
It was a silhouette on the left.
Was that it?
Yeah, I saw the black lines.
It was so fast, though.
Yippee!
It was so fast, I couldn't even tell what it was.
Silhouette on the left, home.
Whoa!
Wow!
Nice.
Hmm.
I will...
Anybody, fishlet.
A little, little fishlet.
It was a plankton size.
little teeny baby all right good night hmm
but this one we know oh wait we can use the anchor what does
that do
wait okay let that do
i was jolted awake one heavy anchor was enough to keep the
boat in place and protect it from drifting too far with a
dangerous current.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Hungry.
I feed you.
Yeah, just less movement.
My jacket got all wet.
Okay.
You know, we have bigger...
We are stranded, you know.
You want me to make you?
I can knit you a seaweed jacket instead.
A note So if I'm not the same After my contract Sink me D
Love your hat It's so cute Thank you Oh Oh Oh He obviously
did not have a Captain Whiscus To help him out Yeah
okay Damien yeah it must have been him I think right it's
had the D at the bottom wait no I don't have a net
I don't have a net get out of here get out of here I wanted
the net to throw on you
I wonder what the umbrella will do
now you see me now you don't
oh okay am i gonna get jump scared don't attack me don't
attack me
oh oh it worked
i hid behind my umbrella hoping it didn't have object
permanence i was relieved when i saw No trace of it after
peaking again.
Good to know.
Yeah, it's just a dumb little guy.
We didn't need to give our food at all.
But we do need food.
Toddler stretch with the fish.
Who would have thought that the fish would be dumb?
Hmm.
Hope you're not hungry, Rogue.
Good night.
Island, island, island.
Yes.
I see them coconuts.
This place has coconuts.
Oh, we got this one again.
Fish fear her.
Yeah!
This new tanker!
Okay.
What if it's a net?
I think I'll be so sad.
Treasure Island.
We found the one piece.
Everybody.
This is it.
And inside is the Philosopher's Legacy.
Whoa.
Peckish.
Yeah, you're peckish.
What I'm going to do is...
Oh.
I'm going to repair the boat, actually.
Oh, wait.
I thought it took two stamina, but it only takes one.
The one piece is real.
It's real.
Since we have a coconut and an energy bar, I'm gonna eat one
of them.
And then we'll open it and see what's in there.
No energy to eat?
Wait then what does the coconut do?
Wait, what does the...
Oh it costs an energy to eat.
Are you...
It's a...
We need one energy to eat it.
Now I'm confused.
Now I don't know what it does at all.
It costs an energy to eat it, but maybe it gives us, like,
total food or something.
It's the ghost again!
Back!
Back, you ghost!
Get away, get away, get away, get away.
Yeah, because you have to break it.
Yeah, that's probably it, right?
Hmm?
Are you blushing at me?
I can use the flashlight.
Honestly, not much I can use.
Good night.
Let's see if anything happens.
Oh.
You do not sleep very well.
Oh, come on.
I shut my eyes tight to keep my mind from spiraling in case
it was sleep paralysis.
Then I fell asleep.
Yeah, see?
Easy, easy.
Uh...
Okay.
I'm not a fan of coconut flavor foods.
Will you accept any and all coconut snack offerings?
Yes.
Actually, oh my gosh.
You know what one of my favorite candies is?
Wait, I forgot the name of it.
Wait.
It's the coconut and chocolate candy.
And then there's a little...
There's a little almond...
There's a little almond in it.
Almond joy!
Yes, yes, yes!
Hi, Haminto!
Thank you for streaming, especially today since my birthday.
Come on, Bob!
Happy birthday!
And Captain Oiscus says, Happy birthday too!
Yeah, almond joys are so good!
Oh my gosh.
Can't wait for you to teach other sensei?
Me teaching others?
We'll see about that.
I haven't had one in forever.
Me too!
I haven't had one in so long.
Oh shoot, it's the fish one again.
Do I have anything that I can even grab them with?
The bucket?
A bucket.
I don't think Home and Joy exists here.
I won't...
Oh, we just scooped it out.
Yeah, if you ever get a chance to try one.
It really is just all, it's, it's, it's coconut with an
almond on it and then wrapped in chocolate.
So delicious.
Almond joy craving in three.
Shh, stop it.
I'm craving food at all.
Maybe it is better for both of us to say.
Both of us if they never see us again.
Okay.
Row, you are so, such a downer.
You are such a downer.
Salian.
I'm not gonna feed you next time.
Unless you sing me a sea shanty.
Entertain me, Row, and you will get food.
For now, I rest.
They have little almond joys for Halloween candy.
You can buy a bag for the trick-or-treat.
Or as an excuse.
my first time going to be at the at my maid cafe during
Halloween so I wonder if I'll get any trick-or-treaters I
actually have no idea I've never I haven't been I haven't
had Halloween at this maid cafe yet
luckily managed to stabilize it with the heavy anchor okay
good yeah I'm whiskers you're hungry?
I wonder if we let Rowe die.
Rowe, if I get some food, I'll give it to you.
You're not going out for Halloween?
No, probably not.
I'll be streaming.
I have an idea already for Halloween.
Today's your lucky day.
Today's your lucky day!
This run ain't so great.
Peaceful night!
Come on!
You're peckish already?
I just fed you!
In this tiny boat.
Even my peg leg is starting to ache.
You know about Phantom Pain?
How do I know what I was about to say!
Don't break up Phantom Pain!
When something's gone, but it still hurts like it's there.
Phantom Pain.
But I'm I'ma mama-ma-ma-ma-ma-ma-maa
ma-maa-ma-maa-maa-maa-maa ma-maa-maa-maa-maa-maa-maa.
Meow, meow, meow, meow.
They're inflated like a damn fiddle!
Wait, what if we have Post-fiddled Kazuhira Miller on our
boat.
I'm so sorry.
Ro, Kaz?
They are brothers.
I will wait until tomorrow.
Or whenever I have low food again.
But I have an energy.
And I'll eat the coconut.
The bottle.
Wait, can I grab that?
Do I have anything to grab it with?
I'm unprepared!
Never mind.
Oh man!
This run is so lame!
Oops!
I didn't mean to do that!
It's far out of reach, so we may never know what the message
it held or the reason it ended up here.
Yeah, not even the bucket, I know, right?
Or just like swim out a little bit.
like an anti-Robot's foot.
Okay, I'll eat it tomorrow.
I'll eat it tomorrow.
What if it's like my message from last run?
That'd be so funny.
ASL, baby girl.
Okay, five food.
Rob will eat tomorrow.
Good night, Captain Whiskers.
But Captain Whiskers eats every day.
Captain Whiskers eats lots and lots.
Oh I guess we'll go to the ride again It didn't seem to do
anything bad last time So
Okay He's the captain He's the captain, exactly Did anything
happen?
No Can something happen?
I wonder Here, okay he's happy but not Alright here I go
Whoa!
Nice!
That was so much food!
Make it.
Seedweed, seaweed, seaweed.
Oh, we got it.
I have enough to knit him a seaweed jacket now, for real.
And my plastic bottle.
I am trying to get real hungry, though, guys.
so maybe if we kill ourselves somehow and then we
finish up hmm I'm gonna try sleeping I wonder if the
dangerous creature will get us no literally nothing happened
oh I felt the impact of a small rock scraping beneath the
boat so I got up to take a look around the area pretty
sketchy, but I still chose to go back to sleep and let the
waves carry me out there.
This way I can't blame myself for picking the wrong
direction.
Oh.
Well.
You should be able to weave a large signal from seaweed and
plastic bottles at this point.
That's, this guy is not an engineer.
He's a, he's, he's a, he's a second, he's the crewmate.
Wait, no.
What is the second hand?
guy up to captain what is it called he is first mate he is
the first mate to this captain that's all yeah worthless
junk stop telling me how I how I feel stop calling me what I
am stop peaceful night this run is kind of do do garbage
somehow we've made it to day 20 and it feels like nothing
has happened we've been surviving off of like nothing
contractor what a heartless skunk oh i'll feed you but we're
we have no food it's rose fault row row l oh man
Oh my gosh.
Every time I think it's over, we get one tiny little thing.
Good night, Captain Whiskers.
Have a good night.
Nah, I think the junk is...
I think the junk is for...
Is for if you get so hungry.
It says, like, I'm not desperate enough to eat it.
Do you have a shirt on?
Condition is 9%.
I saw someone stranded on a rock in the distance.
Before I could even question it, I started hearing this
weirdly calming serene melody.
Trying to get closer, however, silenced the singing.
I woke up with bleeding ears and half of my body hanging out
of the boat.
I scrambled back before it tipped over.
Wow, what a time to offer repair services.
I have some pain.
He didn't die.
That would have literally killed us had we not just repaired
the ship.
That's crazy.
How are we still on this run?
Like I said, every time I try to kill myself, nothing works.
I mean, I could always just stop repairing, you know, but
like...
Oh, okay.
I guess I'll fish.
Hmm.
I just act good.
I know.
The streamer look.
Something kill me!
Ah.
Oh, this one's new.
Oh.
Stay awake?
Yes.
Staring contest?
You lose?
I think they're shy.
You did not sleep very well.
Oh my gosh, I have no...
Guys, we got one food left.
It's so bad.
I have enough energy to, like, lift my hand up for cat and
whiskers, and that's it.
I had to pull in all nighter.
The sea had eyes.
I was locked in a staring contest with it.
When I lingered on my friend, hunger in its gaze, I was not
its target.
By dawn, I woke up exhausted, but relieved as it left
without harm.
What if we...
Oh, no, it's the sharks!
I was going to say, What if we, uh, let him, what if we let
Roe die?
Uh, I don't think I have anything here that will take out
these guys, so I am unprepared, yeah.
Uh, jump scare warning?
3, 2, 1.
The end!
Oh, I'm getting kissed by a fish.
Sleeping with the fish!
Fishes!
Cause of death.
Torn into pieces.
I think cause I was, uh...
I think cause I, um...
Was injured.
That's me!
Does that count as a new death?
Oh yeah, sleeping with the fishes claimed by the sea.
So we had the sleeping with the fishes sank with Dorothy,
seagulls.
The funny about your food troubles is that Bro has a chance
to fish if you talk to him.
No way, does it really?
That's so funny.
This one, though, is kind of freaky.
If I'm not the same after my contract, sink me.
I want to know more about the lore.
What a funny little game, though.
I hope you guys enjoyed Don't Sleep with the Free Shoes.
It was silly.
Just a little interesting type of game.
thank you captain minto and captain whiskers for the boat
ride have a good meal thank you thank you thank you oh dorko
thank you so much for the peek thank you for the stream good
job navigating the city captain and nice win earlier i hope
dinner is delish maybe you dominated us in time but we'll
practice and come back stronger we'll win next time you'll
see good night good night good night thank you guys thank
you thank you it was fun to watch thank you captain thank
you for watching i really appreciate it it's over already
time flies with mint yeah it's time for me to let you go and
if it loves you it'll come back so you guys will come back
right right
yesterday my dad got hurt bad he's okay now that's good so
this search is a good distraction thank you for cheering me
up oh jerry i'm glad i'm glad he's okay now though but yeah
is a scare.
Thanks for the three-hour tour.
Happy Dindun.
Thank you!
Everybody get something delicious to eat and maybe offer a
little bit to me as well.
Any game is fun when you're the one playing.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Same time tomorrow?
Yes.
Same time tomorrow.
Have a good time, Zoe, and I will see you and I'll see you
next time!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!
Uh, uh...
Yo!
That's a hoi backwards.
Oh my gosh, I should have had my eye patch on.
So I could be a pirate.
I won't scatter your ashes to the heartless mighty I'm gonna
go eat sushi what should we do bye bye